I've sadly been bracing for this to happen
and it happened a little bit with the November
impeachment
hearings in the house intelligence committee.
I mentioned to you, I got a few antisemitic
messages.
I don't think I can really call them anything
else saying this entire impeachment thing
is a Jewish conspiracy.
You've got Jewish Adam Schiff bringing in
Jewish Lieutenant Colonel Alexander Veneman.
It's all the deep state Jewish plan to take
out Trump.
Gordon Sundland is Jewish, uh, that et cetera,
et cetera.
Earlier this week we had this crazy video
from Christian pastor Rick Wiles saying the
entire movement to hold Trump accountable
for things he has done is a quote, ju KU.
Remember this video from earlier in the week?
That's the way the Jews work.
They're there.
They are deceivers.
They plot, they lie, they do whatever they
have to do to accomplish their political agenda.
This impeach Trump movement is a Jew coup
and the American people better wake up to
it really fast because this thing is moving
now towards a vote in the house and then a
trial in the Senate.
We get out a trial by before Christmas.
This country could be in civil war at Christmas
time.
That's right.
But then as I sat a couple of days ago watching
the impeachment hearings in the house judiciary
committee, I knew that this was about to explode.
You had Congressman Jerry Nadler running the
committee, Jewish guy from Brooklyn.
You add a long time.
He's a longtime Congressman and really a fixture
of that committee.
Some other judiciary committee members also
from Jewish families, certainly Steven Cohen,
actually Tennessee's first Jewish Congressman
ever.
Jamie Raskin who asks questions and then you
had two of the three democratic witnesses,
Noah Feldman, a Jewish lawyer from Boston
and Pamela Carlin, a Jewish lawyer.
So I was grimacing as I anticipated what I
was going to see in my YouTube comments and
in my email this morning, and unfortunately
it is exactly as I feared.
I'm going to show you one email I got now,
excuse the rampant misspellings that are in
it.
This is as received.
I have not corrected them.
The email read Jew boy, you guys are being
obvious.
I thought Jews were crafty.
First it's Adam skiff and Jackie spear getting
their fellow Jews to slam Trump foreigner.
Veneman plus Sunland.
Nice.
Right to Bobby's, I guess they mean obvious.
Then it's bar mitzvah boy NAD duller directing.
Shocker.
Jewish lawyers to say Trump give up.
You will not repulse us.
I guess replace you will not replace him.
Your mistakes.
Too many obvious Jews and some are crazy like
the Carlin woman.
Fortunately it all backfired since we saw
through the Jew plan to hurt T presumably
Trump have fun with four more years.
So I, I'm, I'm half joking but for more messages
like this, check out the comments on my YouTube
channel.
This is getting very ugly and it's unsurprising
but it's, it's not just rhetoric in the sense
that we are seeing a violence against Jews
in real life.
We are seeing people like that pastor Rick
Wiles start to talk about civil war and taking
up arms and picking which side you are on.
So we really shouldn't laugh this off.
And by the way, it's really bad in Europe
and I know that there are many people who
consume American news but don't follow what's
going on in Europe.
It is getting really, really bad.
So I was hoping to be wrong about this and
unfortunately exactly as predicted exactly
as predicted.
And it is bad.
It's bad.
And I'm extraordinarily concerned and I want
to hear from you what, what do you think about
this type of thing?
Did you predict this?
Were you surprised by the degree of antisemitism
that the impeachment hearings have triggered?